it is now almost two months since the
people of this country began to put up
with restrictions on their freedom your
freedom of a kind that we have never
seen before in peace or war and you have
shown the good sense to support those
rules overwhelmingly you've put up with
all the hardships of that program of
social distancing because you understand
that as things that and as the
experience of every other country has
shown it's the only way to defeat the
coronavirus the most vicious threat this
country has faced in my lifetime and
though the death toll has been tragic
and the suffering immense and though we
grieve for all those we have lost it is
a fact that by adopting those measures
we prevented this country from being
engulfed by what could have been a
catastrophe in which the reasonable
worst-case scenario was half a million
fatalities and it's thanks to your
effort and sacrifice